so
today we're going to talk about young
and
i find that tremendously
entertaining
i'm not sure i ever i've ever read
anyone as intelligent as jung except
maybe nietzsche
um
it's funny he's accused of many things
such as starting a new religion
by some rather unscrupulous biographers
but what he did was actually far more
radical than anything he's ever been
accused of
one other thing i should tell you too is
jung has often been accused of
anti-semitism but one of the things that
came to light in last year was that he
was working as an agent for the american
government during world war ii
and frequently set updates on hitler's
psychological condition to the highest
levels of the american government he
never told anybody about that
so
so you know that's a little hard on old
accusations of anti-semitism i think
which i've never thought had
held any merit anyways
so young
he was a strange guy in many ways
extraordinarily
imaginative
he could
get lost in daydreams
and was a tremendously powerful
visualizer
and
a lot of what he
discovered
was a consequence of
engaging in
long-term
elaborated fantasies
and in these fantasies
he could have conversations with
figures of his imagination
and
communicate with them
i had a client at one point who was a
very prolific dreamer and
she could talk to her characters in her
dreams and ask them what they meant
symbolically and they would tell her
that was really something i've only seen
one person who who was capable of doing
that she was
i don't know if it helped her that much
in the final analysis but she could do
it
but young was very very interested in
the depths of the human imagination now
his
body of work
can be viewed as an amalgam
of many things but
he had deep knowledge of latin and greek
and he'd studied
alchemical manuscripts
for many many years as an older man so
he was very interested in the emergence
of the idea of science from what he
considered the collective imagination
but in many ways his primary modern
intellectual influences i would say were
nietzsche
and
freud
jung really set out some somewhat like
piaget
to
address the gap between religion and
science
but he did it for different reasons than
piaget
jung took nietzsche's comments about the
death of god very
seriously and one of the things
nietzsche
predicted
at the end of the 19th century
was that
there were going to be two major
consequences of the collapse of formal
religious belief he believed that that
would lead people to a morally
relativistic condition that would prove
psychologically intolerable because
if you adopt a morally relativist
position and you take it to its final
conclusion then
everything is of equal value and there's
no gradient between things there's no
better and there's no worse and in the
final analysis you might say well
there's no good and there's no evil and
the problem with that is you can't
actually orient yourself
in a world that has those properties
because in order to act as we've already
talked about with regards to the
cybernetic models you have to be aiming
at something that's better than what you
have now or there's no reason to expend
the energy and so you need the gradient
you need a value differentiation in
order to act
and nietzsche's
analysis
was predicated on the idea that if the
value hierarchy collapsed
well not only would people not be
motivated to do anything anymore but
they would also be extraordinarily
confused and depressed because the value
would go out of their life and the
consequence of that would be that they
would become
somewhat nihilistic or maybe absolutely
nihilistic or that they would turn to
ideological rigid ideological systems as
a replacement
now what nietzsche
offered as an alternative to that was
that human beings could create their own
values and so his idea was that the
superman the over man depending on how
you look at it would be the person who
was capable of
transcending the
valueless universe that the decline of
religion had left with us and creating
their own values as a conscious act
the problem with that is that
it isn't obvious that you can create
your own values as a conscious act
because it's not obvious that values are
consciously created
and i think this is why the
psychoanalysts had so much to add
to the philosophical debate
at least the philosophical debate that
developed to the point of nietzsche's
observations
when freud entered the scene
the idea of the unconscious was in the
air but freud
formalized it to a much greater degree
than anyone else had and
freud's theory really is deeply
biological you know his
it's biological it's social as well but
his proposition the proposition that
there's an id
is fundamentally the proposition that
you're not necessarily your
consciousness for sure is not the master
in its own house
now i think
part of the reason that people like to
go after freud there's a variety of
reasons but one of them is that
modern people basically accept radical
freudian presuppositions more or less as
givens now
you know and so if you're a brilliant
thinker and your
thought permeates a society to the point
where
your most radical propositions are
accepted by everyone all that's really
left are your errors
and so it's easy to concentrate on
freud's errors because we've only
digested everything he had to say that
was particularly profound i mean i i
don't imagine perhaps i'm wrong but i
don't imagine that there's anyone in
this room to whom the news that
many of your motivations aren't
conscious
comes as a surprise i mean even
psychologists have admitted that in the
last 20 years you know i mean they talk
about the cognitive unconscious which
which i think is a real sleight of hand
maneuver to stop them from having to
credit
freud with his discoveries and i also
think that freud's notion of the
unconscious is far more sophisticated
than the cognitive scientists notion
because freud viewed the unconscious as
a place that was basically populated by
fragmented personalities
not cognitive schemes of one form or
another and not processes but things
that were like living beings and you
know you think well are there living
beings in your unconscious and the
answer to that is well are you alive or
not
and you're alive so you're composed of
living sub components and they're not
machines or at least not in any way that
we understand machines they're
fragmentary sub-personalities and each
of them have their own
worldview and rationalizations and
emotional structure and goals
and so that's why when you get hungry
you see the world through the eyes of a
hungry person and you think thoughts
about food and your emotional reactions
depend on whether food is available or
whether it isn't and maybe whether or
not the food you want is available and
whether it isn't and
you know that that's nature so to speak
imposing its necessities on you as a
living being and for freud that was the
id
and freud thought of the id really as
something that was primordial and
primitive
and he and
and
and that's one of the things that really
separated him from jung and i think jung
is much more accurate from a from the
perspective of evolutionary psychology
in fact i think he's radically
underestimated as a thinker whose
thought was unbelievably deeply grounded
in biology and like jung was a
remarkable person because
his notion of history and and the
relationship between history and the
human psyche
what covered spans of time that were
really
until modern historians and evolutionary
psychologists started to talk about deep
time and the fact that you know the
entire 4 billion year history of the
world is in some sense relevant to us to
us as beings or at least the 3 billion
3.5 billion year history that there's
been life on the planet
ancient history for european
philosophers was like
500 to 2 000 years ago and young thought
way past that way back farther than that
and started to take into serious account
the fact that our the origins of our
psyche the ground of our psyche is
deeply biological and that it's an
emergent properly so for freud freud's
idea of the unconscious is somewhat
difficult to understand because there's
sort of two elements to it there's the
id which is the source of
primordial motivation and freud
concentrated mostly on aggression and
sexuality and the reason he concentrated
on those two although he concentrated on
what he called the death instinct later
in his life
the reason he concentrated on those two
primarily wasn't because he regarded
them necessarily as the most
compelling of motivations but he
regarded those motivations as the ones
that were most difficult for most people
to integrate successfully into the
social world
so he thought that they were most likely
to be repressed and therefore
underdeveloped and and immature and i
think that's
i think that's a reasonable proposition
i think that modern people would have to
add
eating to that because since the time of
freud we've gone i would say from
a high proportion of sexually
related pathologies to a very very high
proportion of eating related pathologies
but
that's in some sense beside the point
so that's one part of the freudian
unconscious sort of an implicit
unconscious and then the other part of
the freudian unconscious
is those things that have happened to
you
that you've repressed
because you don't
like what they
imply
and you know those are very different
kinds of unconscious because one of them
is dependent on your experience and the
other isn't and you could think of jung
actually as a
a deep archaeologist of the id
and freud
freud thought about it in sort of
primordial terms so his his
angry id would be you know
like a beast that's out of control
but you
recognized that
the unconscious was far more
sophisticated
in many ways than the conscious
parts of your being
and
that it guided your adaptation in ways
that you didn't understand
and that those the ways in which it
guided your adaptation and structured
your understanding were
universal
hence biological
and
far more sophisticated than a
somewhat
primordial notion of biological drive
might indicate
so
one of the things that you might
consider for example is that from the
union perspective
a lot of the forces that ancient people
considered deities
were
personified representations of
instinctual systems
so here's a way of thinking about and
this is a way of thinking about the
collective unconscious which is jung's
in some sense jung's replacement term
for the freudian id
so mars for example is the god of war
roman god of war
and you might say well what does it mean
for
there to be a god of war and the answer
or venus is the god of love actually of
of sexual attraction more particularly
or of sexual possession which is even a
better way of thinking about it
you say well why would people
conceptualize of those
phenomena
as gods
the greeks said for example that human
beings were the playthings of the gods
no that's with shakespeare i'm sorry
there was shakespeare who said that
well here's one way of thinking about it
what's older you or aggression
the answer to that is well you're 23.
and the system that mediates biological
aggression in mammals and their
progenitors is
tens of millions of years old
and if you think you control it
rather than the other way around
you're deluded about your central nature
part of it part of it is that you don't
control it at all
what happens is that you never go
anywhere where you need to use it
and so one of the things that happens to
soldiers in wartime for example is they
go somewhere where they could use it and
out it comes and the consequence of its
emergence is so traumatic that they
develop post-traumatic stress disorder
because they observe themselves doing
things that are hyper aggressive that
they could have never imagined that
someone like them could have
manifested then you think well what
about venus as a goddess
well if you fall in love with someone
who who
is that a choice
it doesn't look like a choice i mean if
it's a choice it's often an incredibly
self-destructive and idiotic choice and
it's often one that ruins people's
entire lives it's more like a state of
possession
and then you might say well possession
by what well it's a dynamic living
system and it's also immortal in some
sense which is another reason why
conceptualizing it as a deity makes
sense
i mean
the phenomena of love which is
the manifestation of a complex
biological system will be a long
long will be around long after you're
gone and was there long before you
showed up
and when it
manifests itself so to speak within you
you're possessed by it
and you do its bidding and you may do
its bidding despite what you most deeply
want
you know modern people tend to think
that the conscious parts of their brain
the
say
or let's say the more newly evolved
elements of their brain because we don't
actually know
what the relationship is between
consciousness
and
the newly developed parts of the brain
the assumption is often made that the
reason we're conscious is because we've
developed a very spectacular cortical
cap
but
consciousness appears to be far older
than that
so that's an erroneous assumption but
we do tend to believe that the most
complex and sophisticated parts of our
brain are the cortical cap the complex
cortical cap that's quite enlarged in
human beings relative to our body size
because it's the most it's the it's the
newest
systems and it's there it's also part of
the systems that allow us to do such
things as communicate with language and
think in abstract symbols
but there's a different way of thinking
about this from a biological perspective
and that is
what makes you think the newest system
is the most sophisticated one
why don't you assume that the oldest
system is the most sophisticated one
because it's been around for well for
example the mechanism in in your
neurological
the mechanism that underlies your
conception of your relationship to the
dominance hierarchy for example
is at least 300 million years old
and
the reason it's lasted 300 million years
is because it knows what it's doing
it's far older than your the parts of
your brain that make you conscious in
the specifically human way
and it's so deeply embedded in your
brain in some sense that you have almost
no voluntary control over it
and that's why for example one of the
things that happens to people who are
depressed
is that
the system that reports their dominance
dominance
status
reports that they're low
now sometimes that's true because
they're not depressed they just have an
awful life and they're actually at the
bottom of the dominance hierarchy and
that's not the same as being depressed
but sometimes it malfunctions so someone
who's competent and well situated in
life and who appears to have everything
that a person
could possibly desire in order to have a
decent and meaningful and positive life
are still catastrophically depressed and
what seems to happen in those
circumstances is that the dominance
counter for one reason or another is
acting as if they're incredibly low
status when they're in fact not and i
think that's a good definition of
clinical depression i also think that
part of the reason that there's mixed
results with regards to antidepressant
trials is because antidepressants don't
help you if you're at the bottom of the
dominance hierarchy
well how could they
you're not depressed you just have a
terrible life
that is not the same thing and they need
to be carefully distinguished because if
you're unemployed and you're facing the
loss of your home and maybe your partner
is going to leave you and your children
hate you
an antidepressant is very unlikely to
fix that now to the degree that
misbehavior on your part called caused
by impulsivity and increased aggression
and decreased mood because of your
reaction to that circumstances is making
it worse
then the antidepressant might help you
and maybe the antidepressant will help
you regain enough cognitive control so
that you can plan your way out of the
situation but as a medication in and of
itself there's no possible way it can
lift you out of those often
catastrophically complex and
disintegrating circumstances whereas if
your
life is fine but you feel terrible
well it's much more likely that an
antidepressant can help with that
because in some sense what it's going to
do is to readjust your dominance the
reporting of your dominance counter so
to speak to the level that's appropriate
for your level of competence which is
really what you want you know people say
you should have high self-esteem i i
would say idiots say that you should
have high self-esteem it's a it's an
unbelievably corrupt construct in many
ways because it's actually very very
highly correlated with baseline levels
of neuroticism negatively which is a
fundamental personality trait and
baseline levels of extroversion so
someone with low self-esteem is
generally someone who's introverted and
has high levels of negative emotion it's
a trait like phenomena it isn't clear at
all that calling that low self-esteem
has any utility whatsoever but then you
also might ask yourself well how much
self-esteem should you have
well that's a very complex question
because you can clearly have way too
much that's what would make you a
narcissist
so i would say your self-esteem
should be roughly equivalent to the
esteem
in which you're held by members of your
society you know your family and your
society because they're judging you at
least in part on your competence
and you shouldn't think that you're more
competent than you are and you shouldn't
think that you're less competent than
you are you should think that you're as
competent as you are and sometimes that
means you're not competent at all
because you don't know what you're doing
and sometimes it means that you're quite
competent now i think it's complicated
by the fact that
you should also regard yourself
not only as who you are
but as who you could be
you know and so if you're of lowly
dominant status which for example in
some sense you guys are because you're
young and you know you're starting your
lives
the fact that there's a lot of potential
that you still are able to manifest
should
tilt the
self-assessment balance in your favor to
a fair degree so
anyways jung was very interested in the
depths of the psyche and
for him the unconscious wasn't a
repository of
repressed
experiences
and it wasn't a repository of
underdeveloped and irritated biological
systems
it was instead
the underlying structure
of consciousness itself
so jung believed that
human experience
as it's consciously manifested
was structured
by underlying
patterns of behavior
that were
specific and unique to to the to the
human
to humankind although shared to some
degree with other animals and then on
top of that
a realm of imagistic and symbolic
representation
that in part was
a consequence of representation of those
underlying behaviors so here's a way of
thinking about it
we act in a human way
whatever that means and we've been
acting in a human way for as long as
there's been human beings
and we've been acting in a mammalian way
for as long as there's been mammals
now human beings are quite peculiar
creatures because not only do we act
we also watch ourselves act and we
represent those actions
and jung believed that as a consequence
of
us manifesting
a specific set of typically human
behaviors over
hundreds of thousands or perhaps
millions of years
we also evolved the cognitive apparatus
that was capable of representing those
patterns of behavior
and that cognitive apparatus expressed
the representations of those fundamental
patterns of behavior
in imagistic and symbolic form and the
basic imagistic and symbolic form is
something like drama
now why would that be well it's it's
obvious in some sense what is drama
drama is the representation the abstract
representation of patterns of behavior
that's what you do when you go to a
movie you watch people
manifest their characteristic behaviors
and then you might note that there's
well there's characteristic
quasi-unique patterns of behavior that
are portrayed in drama
so for example there's the bad guy and
he wears a black hat in a cowboy movie
and whenever you go to a movie it's
pretty clear to you right away who the
good guys are and the bad guys are and
you accept the distinction between good
and bad guys as in a priory acceptable
distinction so jung would say well
that's the action of an archetype what
underlies that is the archetypal story
of the hostile brothers
and the hostile brothers for example are
cain and abel which is the story of cain
and abel in genesis by the way
is really the second story that that's
in that origin myth and it's the first
story about real human beings
right because adam and eve so to speak
were created by god whereas cain and
abel were born the first brothers well
what happened well one of them became
insanely jealous of the other and
murdered him
so that's a pretty harsh story when you
think that you know our the the
the monotheistic religions of of the
west roughly speaking put as one of
their foundational stories the idea that
there's a twin pair of forces operating
the human psyche that can be
conceptualized as brothers who are
murderously opposed to one another
it's like
that's part of the reason why that story
hasn't disappeared it's so powerful it's
so shocking
it's so powerful that it can't disappear
and the reason for that is that it's
true
in a sense it's true like
it's true that
a reasonable drama not all of them
obviously but a
large proportion of them
has a bad guy and a good guy and then
you might say well
what would the archetypes be
well the archetypes would be the
ultimate good guy
and the ultimate bad guy
and there's representations of the
ultimate good guy and the ultimate bad
guy jung was very influenced by
christianity and part of the reason for
that is that he grew up in a state that
was protestant primarily christian and a
number of his immediate ancestors were
pastors so he grew up in an atmosphere
that was pretty saturated by religious
ideas and so a lot of his thinking was
heavily influenced by christianity
so
one of the things he pointed out was
that just like cain and abel
who are archetypes in a sense their
archetypes of the they're the old
testament version of archetypes of the
hostile brothers
christ and satan are archetypes and the
reason they're archetypes is
because virtually by definition
the the satanic symbol so to speak is a
representation a symbolic representation
of everything that's terrible about
human beings it's an archetype you can't
imagine anything worse than that so it's
like a limit case
and then when you go to a movie and you
see bad guys you can think of them as
partial approximations of the archetype
or you can think about them as
the archetype differentiated in a manner
that makes exposure to the archetype
fresh and interesting
because you just don't want to go and
see the same old bad guy over and over
and over you want to explore the entire
complex
behavioral and representational system
of the
archetype of the of evil in every
conceivable situation
and in the same way you want to explore
the archetype of good and the reason you
want to do that in principle
depending on your motivations
is to
control
the influence of
the factors that underlie the negative
archetype in your life and to manifest
the factors that underlie the positive
archetype and that's why you hope for
the good guy
it's also why generally speaking in a
drama
you
embody the good guy while you're
watching the movie so i can give an
example of this so
i one of the things i learned to do with
my son when i took him to movies because
when he was a little guy i took him to
fairly intense movies
and
sometimes too intense but
one of the things i taught him when he
was afraid was keep your eye on the hero
not don't be afraid or it's not real
it's like
you could easily make a case that a
movie is more real than normal life
why would you watch it otherwise
what a movie is is normal life stripped
of everything that's
trivial
so if you strip a representation of
everything that's trivial what makes you
think that isn't more real
so is fiction more real than
life
well is abstraction more real than
reality
it certainly is in many cases i mean
there are people who believe for example
that mathematical representations are
are the most real of phenomena they
certainly if you're a very powerful
mathematician they you certainly become
or if your society is very powerful
mathematically it certainly gives you a
tremendous amount of control over your
environment so the idea that
abstractions aren't real is
that's a silly idea
and the idea that fiction isn't real it
all that indicates is a confusion
about what constitutes real
a movie is a representation of
characteristic behavioral patterns
extending across time
and it can be a more or less useful and
accurate
distillation of those representations
and generally what we assume is that the
greater the
fictional representation
because we make a distinction between
great fictional representations and
you know second-rate fictional
representations
so shakespeare for example
is
a master at exploring the contours of
the archetype
in a complex realistic and useful manner
now you also believed so that there were
these patterns of behavior and and they
would constitute the typical behavioral
patterns of human beings
and then we
evolved a system of representations of
those patterns and
that would would enable us to understand
the patterns in a way that other animals
can't because we're self-conscious right
so what does it mean to be
self-conscious it doesn't just mean that
you know that you exist as a separate
entity like it's not just a state of
conscious awareness it's a knowledge
condition you have at your fingertips a
very large
representational storehouse
of abstract knowledge about what human
beings are like and that's developed
over tens of thousands of years right
it's a collective activity the
generation of all these stories we tell
about each other i mean we have ancient
stories the oldest stories we have by
the way are mesopotamian stories
as far as i know and the oldest
mesopotamian story or one of the oldest
mesotamian stories we have is a hero
story where the
the god marduk
fights a great dragon
and cuts her into pieces and makes the
world
and you might think well
what mesopotamians you know what do you
mean the world's created over the pieces
of a great dragon
well
it's it's a piagetian idea
with a bit of narrative complexity added
to it it's like
well how do you create the world
well you confront the unknown
and you transform it into the known or
you confront unexplored territory and
you transform it into explored territory
and then you might say well what exactly
is the unknown or what exactly is
unexplored territory and a scientist
would say well you know if you walk out
in a field that you've never been in
before
there's soil and material elements and
that's what's really there
but that isn't exactly what's really
there
it depends on your time frame
so one of the things i could say about
that for example is that
if you wander outside the boundaries of
your knowledge
if you wandered outside the boundaries
of your territory when you were an
animal
or when you were a more archaic human
being the probability that you were
going to run into something that was
going to tear you apart and eat you was
extremely high
and so then i could say well the
fundamental nature of the unknown is
that which tears you apart and eats you
and you might think well is that
what sort of
reality is that
and and i would say you know how you
hear evolutionary psychologists talk
sometimes about the fact that we evolved
on the african belt and now our nervous
systems are sort of
adapted for that primordial environment
and not really for the modern
environment and so there's a mismatch
between us and the modern world it's
like i i think that's an absolutely
reprehensible
theory partly because we didn't just
evolve on the valt we've been evolving
for a very long time we spent a lot more
time in trees for example than we did on
the velt and
while we were spending time in trees a
lot of us were eaten by snakes
for example and so that's another reason
why the the unknown itself is
represented as this terrible predatory
reptilian beast
and then the human being is represented
as that which or the conscious element
of the human being which was represented
by the mesopotamians as a god the
highest god actually in the hierarchy of
gods which was a brilliant mesopotamian
realization because the mesopotamians
basically concluded in their drama their
religious drama that the highest faculty
of the human being was the capacity to
consciously attend to the unknown
and to make something new out of it well
that's a piagetian idea right that's
exactly what piaget was talking about
when he talked about
the necessity of
comprehending knowledge as a process
rather than as a collection of facts
it's a process what's the process
confront what you don't understand
boldly go where no one has ever gone
right i mean star trek that's where
uh
systematizing minds get their mythology
you know it's rife with mythology and
its initial statement is a mythological
statement and it's a statement of the
eternal explorer
and that's an archetypal idea and you
know you might say well
are you still threatened by those
terrible things that threatened your
ancestors on the vet and normally people
would say well no because there are no
lions but that's because they they don't
get the categories right
lion is a subcategory of unknown
horrible thing
and you guys are surrounded by unknown
horrible things just like people have
always been surrounded by unknown
horrible things
so because you're just as prone to
disease not quite as prone but
fundamentally you're a finite being and
there's things everywhere that act in a
predatory manner in relationship to you
and you will die
and so the idea that the material
conditions of our environment have
changed in a qualitative manner since
the time we spent on the velt is in it's
an error of category
the mythological categories are
categories that represent
environmental entities so to speak some
of which are social that have existed
for vast stretches of time and which
exceed our capacity to detect with our
senses
so one representation for example
is the great father or the wise old man
and the wise old man or the great father
is fundamentally a representation of the
dominance hierarchy now the problem with
the dominance hierarchy is you can't see
it
but it's there it's really there
and then figures like the great mother
especially the tariff because most of
the archetypal figures come in pairs a
positive element and a negative element
and that's be because virtually
everything that manifests itself to you
in a complex environment if you're a
living being
takes with one hand and gives with the
other
you know so nature is benevolent and
kind and wise and the source of all new
knowledge and also
cancer and malaria mosquitoes and the
tsetse fly and the guinea worm and all
these things that are horrifying and
destructive beyond belief and you're
stuck with both and then society we
talked about this before that's the
great father it's on the one hand here
you are
benevolently protected by your social
surround on the other hand
social structures tend towards tyranny
and authoritarianism and they oppress
the individuals within them at the same
time that they sustain their development
and so that's a dichotomous archetype
and then there's the individual who's on
the one hand a remarkable and wonderful
creature and on the other hand
someone who's capable of
atrocities like those that characterized
the actions of many millions of people
in the 20th century
those are all archetypes
there are more archetypes than that like
the archetype of the predatory reptile
with something to offer which is
essentially a dragon is the most
fundamental archetypal representation
jung found that representation in
alchemical manuscripts mostly in the
form of the earl burroughs which is a
snake that eats its own tail and it's a
symbol of matter and spirit in union
because the snake is sort of matter and
the wings on the snake the dragon make
its spirit so it's like the fundamental
elements of reality are matter and
spirit in some kind of conjoined
state
and
the fundamental task of the human being
is to come to terms with the nature of
that unknown thing now think about it
this way well why would ancient people
represent
the
unknown as such
as a
reptilian self-contained reptilian form
that was both spiritual and material
well here's the reason
first the unknown's dangerous
and you could be its prey
so you better have that representation
at hand and then you might ask well is
that really the unknown and then i would
say well it depends absolutely on what
you mean by really from a darwinian
perspective that was the best way to
conceptualize the unknown
and then you might say well that doesn't
make it real and then i might say
you're are you sure about that is there
anything more real than than
representations derived from darwinian
processes the darwinists would say no
okay so why is it matter in spirit why
is it winged and on the ground at the
same time well
this is you can also understand this
from a piagetian perspective and so that
is because when you encounter the
unknown you separate
the material world in the spiritual
world and the spiritual world is the
psychological world and so what you're
doing when you encounter the unknown is
you parse some of it up into the world
and you incorporate other elements of it
into yourself
and the best way to think about that i
think from a conceptual perspective so
it becomes more understandable is that
what you encounter when you encounter
the unknown is patterned information
and you take some of that patterned
information into yourself even by doing
something as simple as gripping
something you want to pick up because
you're imitating the pattern of the
thing that you want to pick up and
that's how you're transforming its
structure into an element of your being
and so when you're exploring the unknown
it's a constructivist idea you're
simultaneously constructing the world
and constructing yourself and thus the
inference is the unknown is made out of
that which can be parsed out into psyche
and matter
and it's dangerous
so it's a perfectly reasonable
representation and that's why it won't
go away
so jung's fundamental contribution i
would say
is the is his analysis of hero mythology
and i would say that's the fundamental
element of his thinking now the
relationship between that and nietzsche
is fundamentally this nietzsche believed
that once the religious systems
collapsed we would have to consciously
produce our new set of values but jung
believed that the psyche was the source
of all value and so that it wasn't a
matter of creating new values it was a
matter of discovering the values that
were already lying dormant and implicit
within us
so and the next thing i would say about
that is you all know this
you just don't know you know it and so
one of the reasons to be to be educated
from a literary and historical
perspective
is that you can come to understand what
you already know
because if you don't understand it then
there's an element of your being the
element that knows it and acts it out
and there's another element which is
sort of you as a personality that are
completely at odds with one another and
that makes you weak
it makes you something that's divided
within itself
now you're doing everything you can as a
general rule to incorporate this
information
now
for a long time it seems as if as long
as we acted it out and represented it
symbolically
and didn't argue about the assumptions
it was more or less okay but we're past
that now and in order for us to
benefit from the same
protective
structures that our ancestors benefited
from
we now have to understand what they mean
consciously and that's really what jung
was up to
what he was really trying to do was to
resurrect deep religious representations
from the dead so to speak
and to make them conscious so people
could align themselves with them again
now i'm going to show you something that
that's related to that
all right now so
i'm going to show you something from
pinocchio
now this is an initiation ritual
it's a journey to the depths so it's a
journey to the underworld
it's the consequence of a collapse in
previous personality and the
disintegration of that previous
personality into a chaotic state prime
prior to rebirth
now what happens in pinocchio which by
the way was released at about the same
time that world war ii was
was brewing
and which also contains one of the best
representations of
of the
of the individual motivations for
fascism that i've ever seen anywhere
that's the scenes that are associated
with pleasure island remember all the
the puppet is trying to become a real
boy right so he's a marionette to begin
with something else is pulling his
strings well for jung that's your
habitual
state of being
something else is pulling your strings
even the idea that you're autonomous is
the consequence of something else
pulling your strings and for jung
what you needed to do was find out
exactly who and what is pulling your
strings and decide if that's the
direction in which you want to go
and that's really what happens to
pinocchio because we're going to watch
pinocchio part of it in the pinocchio
story he starts out as a marionette now
he's a marionette made by a good father
because geppetto is a good father he's a
good craftsman and so on so he's a
marionette with a benevolent puppeteer
but as soon as he develops some autonomy
then he becomes prey to
forces that are elements of the demonic
archetype in fact the worst bad guy in
the entire movie turns into satan
himself at one point in the movie he
basically has horns and a bright red
face and he manifests himself as so
terrifying that the coyote
coyote
wolf fox
and the cat that are trying to corrupt
pinocchio are terrified because they get
like they're criminals they're petty
criminals and deceptive and and so forth
but when they get a look at who's
pulling their strings it's enough to
terrify them and so
pinocchio goes through a series of
temptations
of various sorts including a freudian
temptation and the freudian temptation
is to remain weak and sickly instead of
becoming a real person so it's an
eatable problem and another
problem that faces pinocchio is that
he's offered false celebrity as a way of
solving his life's problems so he's
offered the opportunity to become an
actor and what that means is a deceitful
fake who's constructed a persona that
makes him appear far more valuable than
he really is so the movie outlines two
pathological modes of movement towards
maturity one being a phony and the other
taking the easy way out and and hyper
uh valuing all your pathology so that
you become dependent
so anyways
and then another mode of pathological
development is offered to pinocchio
which is to do nothing but engage in
short-term impulsive and destructive
play and that's on treasure island but
when he pleasure island but when he goes
to pleasure island he finds that it's
actually ruled by demonic forces with
faceless
entities who are transforming all the
pleasure-seeking marionettes
to braying donkeys who are slaves
it's like
so
pinocchio escapes from that and he does
it basically by jumping into the unknown
and that's where we're going to start
our
exposure to his initiation
okay so now you can imagine what's
happened is he was on pleasure island
and everything went to hell
fundamentally and so he jumped into the
water to escape from that and that's
equivalent to plunging into chaos and so
chaos was
an escape from pathological tyranny
and now he's tried to go home so this is
the
psyche
in its search for maturation runs into
an obstacle which is the tyrannical
element of the great father that it
cannot cope with and it trots home runs
home it's a defeat typical part of a
hero story is the initial defeat of the
hero when he
encounters usually either the terrible
great father or the terrible great
mother
so and so this is a retrogressive
jung would call this retrogressive
restoration of the persona
so it's sort of like maybe you're a
well-adapted adolescent and you live at
home and you're happy adolescent and
everything's good at home and then you
go out to try to be an adult and you
fail and then when you come back home
you try to act like a happy adolescent
again but you're not what you are in
fact is an unhappy adult and if you move
back to the happy adolescent mode of
being then it's it's false and
pathological you can't go home again
another typical motif in literature
now the cricket
i can't tell you everything about this
story
i can tell you a couple of strange
things about it one is that the cricket
is gemini cricket right and the initials
of jiminy cricket are jc and jiminy
cricket was a common southern american
um
mild form of
uh cursing it's the equivalent of jesus
christ and so you might think and of
course
the cricket is pinocchio's conscience
and
well so then you might ask yourself why
in the world would a
pejorative mildly pejorative term for
jesus christ be applied to a cricket
who's guiding a puppet into the water to
rescue his father from a whale why would
any of that happen and the answer to
that is you know why but you can't say
why you can't say
why you know or what it is that you know
but the mere fact that it makes sense
and it does is an indication from a
union perspective that you're operating
at an archetypal level you understand
this
and so i could say here's an example of
why the cricket is a bug
well things bug you
right we say that things bug me well you
should do something about
the things that bug you
because
that's your conscience calling to you
it's it's destiny in some sense
manifesting itself as an unconscious
impulse that really bugs me means
if you can you should do something about
it because you think about it man
there's a lot of things out there that
might bug you but lots of them don't but
some of them do
well why do those bug you and not other
things
well
that's a complicated question but one
potential answer to it is that
there's part of your psyche that's
oriented towards further development
jung would call that the self and that's
like the totality of everything that you
could be
and it's it's it's it's a it's a strange
sort of entity in some sense because
it's partly potential and it's potential
that expands across time but the way
that your potential totality calls to
you in the present
is by placing things in front of you
that are your problem
and they announce themselves as your
problem and they do that by bothering
you
so then if you pick up the task of
fixing the things that bothers you then
you find the pathway to further
expansion of your personality
so and that's what's happening with
pinocchio now one of the things that's
really interesting about the pinocchio
movie that makes it incredibly
sophisticated is that despite the fact
that the cricket is a avatar of christ
so to speak
the cricket has things to learn just
like pinocchio
and so that's very cool because it's so
cool it's so sophisticated because it
means that you do have a conscience that
guides you but until you establish a
dialogue with it
both you and the conscience are immature
you have to establish a conscious
dialogue with it and then interact
together in a manner that propels your
development across time and that'll stop
you from being a marionette of forces
that would make you a braying donkey who
does nothing but slave away in salt
mines
so
okay so pinocchio goes home that doesn't
work and that's where we're gonna start
here
okay so what's happened there
well
many many things at multiple levels of
reality simultaneously and that's the
characteristic of an archetypal story
so on one level pinocchio is too old to
go home he can't go home to his father
because in some sense he's already
transcended his father
so there are things for example that
your father can't help you with and the
reason for that is that you don't he
doesn't know any more about the
situation than you do and he can't and
so that's where his knowledge limits out
so that would be sort of on the personal
level and then on the trans-personal
level which would be the deeper deeper
archetypal level what's happening to
pinocchio is exactly what nietzsche
described at the end of the 19th century
because remember that geppetto is his
creator and now he's dead he's gone and
so pinocchio is bereft of of
placement so to speak he's
his soul is being corrupted
and he doesn't know what to do about it
and when he returns to
his family home or when he returns to
his tradition
what he finds is nothing
okay so then what happens well this is
another thing that you'll swallow with
just no problem whatsoever well this
dove comes along that's sort of golden
and glowing and drops a note right in
front of them now
you may remember and perhaps you don't
but
the star from which the dove comes
is a representation of the blue fairy
and the blue fairy is the positive
element of the unknown in uh pinocchio
movie and so what it basically is saying
that
when you're despairing because your
father has died and your tradition has
nothing to offer that the positive
element of the unknown may provide you
with a message about where to go if you
pay enough attention
that would be an intuition
or it would be the automatic attraction
of your interest to a new thing by
forces that you do not understand so one
of the real ways of coming to grips with
the idea of the act of unconscious is to
understand that
you cannot control what you're
interested in
and so then you might ask
well if it's not you
what is it
and if you think about that problem long
enough you'll start to understand what
jung was talking about because that
is the way that you can understand in
your own life
that
the things that direct you as a being
are not things that you consciously
choose in fact they're not even things
that you can consciously choose
they're directed by other forces
so anyways
the dove drops a message in front of
pinocchio and
and the cricket
now it's the cricket that reads it so
it's the same idea
as what bugs you so to speak the cricket
is the interpreter
okay so now what have we found out well
we found out that
god the father and god the father the
creator are not in fact dead
which is what nietzsche pronounced
but alive in some weird way in this
horrible creature at the bottom of the
ocean
and so what does pinocchio decide to do
he decides to go find him
that's actually what you're doing at
university by the way
for all the chaos that you experience
when you come to university and all the
uncertainty and all the doubt
what you're trying to do is to resurrect
your dead father from the bottom of the
ocean and if you do that you won't be a
marionette
and if you don't you will be
now this is very interesting because the
conscience here plays a very
dichotomous role
so on the one hand pinocchio is often
ahead of his conscience so to speak so
he's taking the leading role and
the dialogue is kind of choppy and
neither of them know exactly what
they're doing but in this situation it's
very paradoxical because
you can see pinocchio's been half turned
into brain jackass at this point
something you might well consider when
you remember your adolescence
so
at in this point that that the cricket
his conscience does two things it warns
him how horrible this is going to be and
how utterly dangerous it is and then at
the same time it helps him prepare and
goes along with him and so it's quite
comical so watch what happens here
and besides it's dangerous
okay so i've cut this a little bit but
what happens in the movie is that he
goes to the bottom of the ocean and he
starts to ask about monstro
and as soon as he asks any of the fish
down there the denizens of the sub
oceanic world where monster is they just
run away and so monstro is he who cannot
be named
right and i'm sure you've encountered
that in your reading before
right that's the that's uh the hallmark
of
in the harry potter series
right see now you've done it
yeah
so this represents something so terrible
that it can't even be talked about okay
so what happens is pinocchio ends up not
only at the bottom of the ocean but he
has to go to the deepest part of the
bottom of the ocean where the most
terrible thing rests
and so
we're cutting to the point where he does
that
so now you might ask how did geppetto
get in the whale and the answer that is
it's never really made that clear in the
movie
but i can tell you some things about
that is that
if you conceptualize your historical
tradition
as a personality like a body of laws and
customs say
it's not alive
it's dead right because it's composed of
the past
and because it's dead it can't come up
with anything new
so if it encounters something new it
it's stopped and that's what's happened
to geppetto is that
he's engulfed by this
entity that represents the absolute
unknown and he cannot figure out how to
get out and the reason for that is none
of the things he knows so none of the
things that history has produced as a
body of knowledge are sufficient to deal
with the fundamental problem
that doesn't mean they're useless
it just means that
just like the puppet is lost without the
father
the father is also lost without the
puppet
and that's
the relationship between you and history
your history when you study history you
think well you're studying a record of
events in the past and that's not right
what you're studying is the
the circumstances that gave rise to you
as a as a being and unless you
understand your history
in every way you possibly can then
you're an incomplete creature
you you don't know enough to move
forward
in the same way your culture
being composed of
dead fathers so to speak
can't progress without you because
you're its eyes
and there's an egyptian story
that features the god horus who i've
talked to you about before who actually
resurrects his father from the dead by
giving him an eye
so gepetto can't figure out how to get
out of this whale without help
so he's kind of pushing up tombstones
there you might note
all right now something very
sophisticated happens here so and i have
to explain it to you at multiple levels
at the same time so now
gepetto
is hungry
and
when the whale opens its mouth a lot of
fish come in
now one of the things i want you to
think about you can just put this in the
back of your mind is that one of the
oldest system one of the oldest
symbolic representations of christ is a
fish
and all of his followers were fishermen
and so there's this weird relationship
between the messianic figure who's at
the base of it at least at the base of
christian culture and the idea of things
that are pulled up from the depths now
here's what happens in this part of the
movie it's so amazing
so gepetto is looking for fish and the
reason for that is he doesn't think he
can get out of the whale and so he might
as well have some fish while he's while
he's in there
and so he's given up on getting out now
what happens is that the whale swallows
pinocchio as if he's a fish
so pinocchio is put into the same
category as fish and it happens it
happens to gepetto a couple of times he
mistakes pinocchio for a fish you'll see
so what that means in some sense is that
geppetto can't distinguish between
the fish that will feed you for the day
and whatever it is that pinocchio
represents and so you could think about
pinocchio as a fisherman instead of as a
fish and so you can think about it this
way and here here's a here's a an old
saying
if you give a man a fish you feed him
for one day but if you teach him to fish
you feed him forever and so the idea is
it's better to develop the skill to
acquire something than it is to have the
thing
now what pinocchio represents is
he's like a meta fish i know this is a
strange way of thinking about it
geppetto's problem isn't that he's
hungry
his problem is that he can't get out of
the whale and so what he's fishing for
isn't something to eat it's
something that will help him get out of
the whale but he can't recognize the
difference between the proximate
solution
which is so that he'll just no longer be
hungry so he's got a very short-term
outlook and a solution to the much
broader problem so what happens is the
whale swallows a bunch of fish and
pinocchio's in there and geppetto is
fishing away and he catches pinocchio
and pinocchio announces himself and
geppetto
says
tells him to be quiet because he's
interfering with him fishing and then
when he turns to hug pinocchio because
he wakes up he actually hugs a fish and
then he discards the fish
so then he figures out that pinocchio's
there then geppetto decides that well
they're going to have to live inside the
whale and it's another idea of his
blindness at this point because he's
he's composed of the dead past so to
speak so what pinocchio does is start to
destroy the ship itself which is what
they're floating in the whale to start a
fire
and the fire makes the whale mad enough
to spit them out and the whale then
transforms itself into a dragon tries to
kill them because it's a fire breathing
entity at that point and so part of the
understory is
it's better to figure out how to fish
than to fish
or that more profoundly it's better to
figure out how to do something than to
merely benefit from the thing itself
pinocchio represents that which can do
new things so he's a hero and he's
willing to destroy part of the current
order that's the ship in order to
produce a new
strategy that will actually free them
from the whale now he wants to get his
father out of there too so that's what
happens in the next five minutes i would
say
this way
she was such
oh
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
already
hey
i gotta get in there
[Music]
oh
okay so now there's a shock here because
essentially in some sense
the entity that's going to provide the
solution to this very complex problem
has arrived on the scene but it's quite
damaged
first of all it's been speaking
improperly
right so that's an adolescent
representation so it braze a lot of
nonsense
and it's been corrupted in a variety of
ways and so you know to to some degree
what that means is that as you mature
and you're moving away from your mere
marionette status your interaction with
society like rousseau said corrupts you
in all sorts of ways i mean you're
participating in that corruption but it
still happens but in the representation
in the movie the truth of the matter is
it doesn't matter if you've been
corrupted to some degree
as long as you haven't absolutely
sacrificed your capacity for true speech
and vision so you know that's a pretty
hopeful
message because pinocchio is by no means
a perfect entity but he might be good
enough
[Music]
see that's also an indication there of
why people are often unwilling
to
form a representation with uh
so to speak form a relationship with the
archetype of the great father because to
some degree the archetype is a figure of
perfection and the individual in
relationship to that archetype is always
pathologically flawed and so the
embarrassment of that realization which
is exactly what's happening to pinocchio
right now is often enough to stop people
from doing it so what what that would
say to say what that means in some sense
is that in order for you to mature
in in the fullest possible manner you
have to
understand the the manner in which
you're deeply flawed in relationship to
the to your
your potential as it might be
historically determined and that's a
very bitter thing to do you know it's
much easier and people do this all the
time to engage in half-witted formulaic
ideological criticisms of the system as
a whole it's like
you know the probability that the system
is more flawed than you is pretty damn
low so you might want to start with you
know getting rid of your donkey ears and
your tail and stop bringing nonsense
before you judge the entire
you know
historical
process by which human beings have come
into being
so anyways that's kind of what that
means
[Music]
uh
come
okay so this is very interesting too
because so pinocchio ends up being a
master of fire well you can think about
that as
there is a book written a while back by
a primatologist
who also wrote demonic males richard
rangham and he talked about the origin
of fire and as far as rangham is
concerned we invented fire about two
million years ago and that enabled us to
cook food and that enabled us to swap
intestinal length for brain
so if you look at a chimpanzee you know
chimpanzees are like the ultimate in
couch potatoes right they're they're
they're about this high and they're
shaped like this they have this huge
barrel body and the reason they have
that is because they eat leaves and so
they have to spend like eight hours a
day eating leaves they will eat meat if
they can get it they have to spend like
eight hours a day eating leaves and just
chewing them over and over because like
leaves a they don't want to be eaten so
they're pretty tough and inedible and b
they don't have any nutritive quality to
speak of so the chimpanzee has to spend
all of its time chewing which is rather
mindless endeavor all things considered
whereas human beings two million years
ago or thereabouts invented fire and as
a consequence of that we could cook meat
and meat is incredibly energy uh rich
and so and it's easy to digest once it's
cooked and so the consequence of the
invention of fire was that
we're the way we are today we could have
a brain instead of a gut
and so the idea that pinocchio's
mastery of fire
and it's as something more than merely a
means of cooking that's how it started
out right but you can think of our
entire technological
capacity as stemming from the mastery of
fire now the other thing you can think
of and this is very much worth
considering is that
pinocchio masters fire and that turns
the whale into a dragon and so the idea
there too is that and this is an old
idea is that
our technological prowess
is something that makes
nature itself angry and of course you
might say well do you believe this and
the answer to that is well how many of
you have environmentalist leanings and
that's exactly the story that you're
following because you're still wondering
about whether or not mastery of fire was
in somehow against the natural order and
then it will end up in all of our deaths
and you know that's a reasonable thing
to worry about but
not mastering it was going to end up
pretty badly too so
[Music]
so here what happens is that in the
midst of this complete chaos pinocchio
has a choice and the choices he can
either save himself which is a very very
selfish choice and reduces him to an a
historical individual because he has no
relationship left with his father or he
can put his himself at great risk and
rescue his father you know finish the
process stop his father from drowning
and and completely
okay so
[Music]
pinocchio dies
and then his father brings him home
and so because he's rescued his father
the benevolent spirit of nature appears
resurrects him
and turns him into a real human being
[Music]
so it's pretty funny as far as i'm
concerned that the answer to nietzsche's
greek question manifested itself in 19
mid 1930s in the forms of an form of an
animated child's movie
so you know and that's and that's an
example that's an example of a number of
things it's an example of how archetypes
work it's also an example of how artists
are on the edge of discovery all the
time and they discover things they don't
even understand
so
we'll see you next tuesday
[Applause]